the media are obviously very insecure
about this fact you can tell
that the media and the big tech and the
democratic elected officials are
insecure
because they explode whenever you call
them on it
a susan ferreccio from the washington
examiner was just speaking with brian
stelter
you know brian stelter of cnn fame and
she brought up how the press are not
asking joe biden
about anything they're not asking about
any of the scandals that have cropped up
brian stelter i thought his head was
going to explode he's running for
president of the united states and this
is serious this this is not
last year's news it's whether or not his
son
was coordinating to get him to talk to
these ukraine oligarchs and he was
benefiting from it i mean
it's just it's really dirty
forgive me bryce delta then i want to
move on to the google which is a related
story brian
i you know you i said it was last season
you're saying it's new uh
i think bottom line is we don't know
what is real and what is fake in these
emails if there is anything real in them
yeah but that doesn't stop any from from
from reporting the mueller and the
dossier and all that stuff
i understand that you have a lot of
resentment about now now we have ethics
okay now we have ethics don't you dare
don't you dare act like newsrooms didn't
have ethics
in 2017 and 2018. well i know they thank
you well you can't you can don't dare me
all you want brian i've been doing this
for 30 years so
say whatever you want it's my view and i
have a right to say it i wasn't
my view is that the news media was
unethical with mueller like i said one
time i don't quite get right
yes the news media were unethical with
mueller and with
every other hoax of the past four years
what they're saying now what brian
salter is saying now is we don't want to
ask joe biden about
the document dump that we just saw that
shows
collusion and corruption and
whatever other nefarious crime they
accused trump of for the past four years
that shows joe biden committing those
crimes in ukraine and china
we don't want to ask him about that
because we don't know if it's true
you're journalists you're reporters
you're supposed to find out if it's true
right now you're using this lame excuse
that it's russian disinformation the
director of national intelligence and
the doj
and the fbi all came out and said that's
bs it's not russian
disinformation so how about you ask
about it you didn't mind asking about
the completely fabricated
christopher steele dossier which was
paid for by the hillary campaign and the
democrats
you didn't mind asking him about that
you asked about that all the time you
don't mind asking about this ridiculous
conspiracy theory that donald trump is a
white supremacist
that nobody ever floated until he ran
for president as a republican that he
disavows
disavows all the time you don't mind
about that you don't mind asking about
the
the taxes or the stormy daniels or
whatever all that nonsense
they have no ethics whatsoever and the
reason he's exploding about it is
because he knows it i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you